Apple biggest company in the world has
just had its big annual Apple event
where we're unveiling the new products
and the new
technologies and Tim Cook did this by
opening the show with a skit that he had
filmed in which he is accountable to
Mother
Earth Mother Nature Mother Nature
welcome to Apple how how was the weather
getting
in
the weather was however I wanted it to
be let's cut to the chase in 2020 you
promis to bring Apple's entire carbon
footprint to Zero by 2030 Henry David
the row over
here said we have a profound opportunity
to build a more sustainable future for
the planet we share I think our 10:00
said the same thing they all do all
right this is my third corporate
responsibility gig today so who wants to
disappoint Point me first well we've got
some updates we're excited to share with
you materials status is there a
materials person
here yes we are in the process of
eliminating all plastic from our
packaging by the end let me guess 50
years from now when someone else is left
holding the bag by the end of next year
actually oh wow and it goes on and on
and on we'll cut it off there I
can this
is e exhibit 375,000
that our civilization is returning to a
pagan kind of public
religion this is just the opposite of
Christianity Tim Cook is sitting there
and he's going to be accountable to that
higher power that rules over him and
what is that higher power is that higher
power God no it's a nature
Spirit we see in the Bible as people
begin to become aware Ware of the one
true God the Lord Our God the
distinction between the true God and all
the fake Gods is that all the fake gods
that people worship they're just kind of
nature Spirits they're they're lower
worldly kind of entities God himself is
outside of the world he created the
world he is the unmoved Mover he is he
is perfectly himself and then he in an
act love creates everything including
the world and he says don't worship
worldly things don't become worldly but
look to the things of the
spirit what does Apple say here no no no
we're just going to worship literally
the world we're literally going to
worship mother nature and why are we
going to do that well because we want to
make sure that in this fleshy
terrestrial life we get to keep
appeasing the spirits of the sky the
spirits of the the oceans the uh
principalities and powers and spiritual
wickedness in high places and we don't
even notice it most people are going to
watch that if you're listening to this
show you probably are a little uh more
in tune with with the underlying message
of this kind of propaganda but most
people are going to watch it they say oh
that's kind of cute hahaa Mother Nature
is uprating the CEO of Apple T okay
whatever moving on and you don't
recognize that the kind of understanding
of human nature and religion that's
being presented here is the exact
opposite of the religion that built our
entire civilization but but also that
this is the normal kind of religion that
exists has existed most places on Earth
for most of the history of the world
other other than after the Incarnation
this is this is normal paganism and as
our country and our culture is giving up
Christianity we're just returning to
that we're doing the same thing that the
Canaanites used to do we're worshiping
nature and we're sacrif iing our
children to to appease our false gods
that's what we're doing and and there's
nothing new Under the Sun and we we
think that we're very modern and
scientific and Innovative and we're not
we're
just we're either going to choose good
things that have been around for a long
time or we're going to choose bad things
that have been around for a long time
right now go to balanceof nature.com use
promo code noes living a healthy
lifestyle is not always easy especially
when you're always on the go you need
simple manageable routines to make sure
you're getting the proper nutrition
every day that is why I'm a huge fan of
balance nature balance of nature fruits
and veggies are a great way to make sure
you're getting essential nutritional
ingredients every single day their
capsules are packed with 100% whole food
that you can take at any time balance of
nature uses a cold vacuum process that
preserves the natural phytonutrients in
whole fruits and vegetables and
encapsulates them for easy consumption
balance of nature sent a bunch of their
products down to the studio for my team
to try we all love them make fruits and
vegetables part of your diet your body
will thank thank you and hopefully
balance of nature will send more
products so these hyenas that steal my
balance of nature won't be able to get
all of them go to balance of nature.com
use promo code NS kwes for 35 bucks off
your first order as a preferred customer
balanceofnature.com promo code nlls kwes
for 35 bucks off your first order
balanceof nature.com promo code nolles
now speaking of false religions and
powers of the air did you see this story
I have to get to it CU I know Walsh is
going to get to it and he's going to
spread his ridiculous prop Anda so I've
got to get to it there's a story coming
out of Mexico that
ufologists have presented to the
Mexican
authorities
mummified UFO ET corpses and you look at
the corpses and they look like little I
don't know terracotta figures or
something they look like little little
stonework that some eccentric would have
around his garden and they they purport
to they look just like ET I mean like
actually from the Steven Spielberg movie
and they say these are the bodies of
aliens and see that's not it's not human
DNA and it's not a human shape it's an
alien and to me it looks like someone
just carved this out of cement but they
say no no that's an alien now there's a
little bit of important context here I'm
going to pull this up because this is
the part that Walsh is not going to read
on his
show you can you can read the whole
article everyone's going to be saying
this is proof that aliens exist well
here we have let's
see here we have a key quote from this
article the claims by the self-claimed
ufologist have not been proven the
claims about the DNA the claims about
this not being recognizable as human or
made by humans they have not been proven
and Mr Maan has previously been
associated with claims of discoveries
that have later been
debunked
so it's just fake guys it's fake because
aliens are just demons for liberals and
atheists that's all it is it's just
maybe a scop to distract us from actual
pressing political matters um and
religious matters or maybe it's demonic
in nature or maybe it's just some weirdo
who got fooled but the headline you're
going to see is alien bodies discovered
and the actual story is guy who made
disproven claims makes
more similarly to be disproven claims
that's that is what's going on here boy
what a great clip that was now make sure
that you subscribe to the Michael NS
YouTube channel ring that Bell see you
next time